building a new life in Andromeda starts
with a search for solid grind and a safe
harbor the search for our golden world
I'm soo-hyun warred parts of the Nexus
science team and the science officer
assigned to the Tammis I'm here to
explain the basics of the golden worlds
were planning to it happen without mass
relays our first wave of arks will focus
on a pocket of stars called the Helius
cluster in a galaxy of 1 trillion stars
Helius has rich resources and seven
promising golden worlds we've labeled
habitats 1 through 7 these worlds
represent our best chance to find a new
home golden world should not just be
capable of supporting life but should
also be rich in minerals to supply our
colonies and the initiative itself the
Nexus requires vast quantities of
helium-3
water ice and element 0 to continue
functioning the more resources we gather
the more upgrades we can complete on the
nexuses infrastructure the more
colonists we can then awaken from
cryosleep there's no way to know for
sure what state these golden worlds will
be in until we get there but our surveys
have given us some preliminary data
habitat 1 is an average world with vast
underground rivers despite the dry
desert climate temperatures are well
within a comfortable range for
settlement habitat to a large moon
orbiting a gas giants is expected to be
rich in minerals and can potentially act
as a resource for generations to come
habits had three plays host to lush
jungle canopies and rolling hills while
habitat for scan suggests an immense
wealth of liquid surface water making it
an ideal candidate as a life-sustaining
world for our turian and Corian
colonists habitat five appears to be a
perfect home for dextro protein life
scan suggests habitat six has white
oceans and a temperate climate last of
all habitat seven currently has all the
markers of a tropical paradise this will
be our first destination upon arrival
600 years from that and quite possibly
your future home Pathfinder teams will
investigate these planets to determine
their viability this includes everything
from pacifying unforeseen threats
underlying with potential indigenous
populations to solving environmental
problems in an attempt to secure
suitable placement for Seto and I both
ones and I post is established word a
sense of a nexus and more colonists can
be awakened to continue the migration
process for those of
these first steps it should also be
noted that some worlds may already be
the sovereign soil of an existing
culture a concern we will need to treat
with respect
is out there waiting to be discovered at
least seven worlds
our best chance to make that dream a
reality
our power to give you a head start once
we arrive
but the next steps my life firmly with
you
in Andromeda is our future
that brings us closer
[Music]